got milsap on a switch which means he's
going right through the defense
royce o'neill doesn't want it mike
connolly does his three is perfect
this is the best three-point shooting
team in the end that passing we talked
about
turn it on high the blender gets a wide
open shot for mike conley and i like the
fact that
utah their a game in game two they are
playing
wonderfully again today conley for three
adding mike conley already and ingles
will push into the front court
mike conley again wide open three
and that's going to necessitate the
timeout right away seventh career
playoff game clarkson found him wide
open denver flat footed the three
nothing but net down to five
conley's got jokic on the switch the
step back three good
that is a little run stopper for utah
you hedge in now that corner you're in
this line of sight he'll get it to you
ingles stopped mike conley
speaking of which he's trying to figure
out how he's
fit in because he attracts so much from
the defense
now you on offense have to make the
adjustment and speaking of which how
about mike conley coming back in the
bubble
the much-needed offensive threat from
behind the three for
the utah jazz you see something in him
that says you know what we may need that
spark
in the next game early on to create some
kind of momentum defensively for us
mike collins just got to stop it
congratulations on the birth of the new
baby to you and mary
and more specifically my partner jim
jackson from the
ohio state university says
congratulations thank you thank you so
much
okay so you had a career night the three
pointers that you were making today you
made it look so
seamless and effortless can you please
tell us what it felt like out there
um man i was just truly happy to be back
with these guys uh being in quarantine
is not easy
four days uh 30 minutes out of the day
you get to go outside and maybe touch a
ball
shoot in a parking lot like just find
ways to stay active um
just to be out there and play the game
guys made it easy for me tonight
let's talk about your teammates just now
when they're walking off the court you
all were saying goodbye just because you
had to stand here with me
it seems like they're missing you
already how close has this unit become
very close um one of the closest teams
i've been a part of i've been a part of
some great squads
and this one's right up there guys
really really do care about each other
go out there and just compete you saw
our guys at the end we're even still
competing just on the defensive end
and that's what we want from our guys to
just continue to play for each other
okay so what can you learn from what you
did today
for the rest of the series well you know
honestly
when you win a game in the playoffs no
matter how many points you win by it's
just a win
um it can swing anyway uh in the series
so
for us is to stay consistent defensively
continue to try to
get in the paint on offense defensively
try to keep them off the boards
and just keep playing for each other and
share the ball thank you so much
congratulations again your teammates are
over there yelling for you to have more
babies
i don't know about that but uh thank you
all right thanks a lot
all right thank you